housing associations exist to provide
affordable rented homes that's what they
do they're independent private social
enterprises that exist for the benefit
of the community and they do that by
providing rented homes
if we were to sell
those houses then they become owner
occupied nothing wrong with that but it
means there is one fewer available house
to rent and we have a massive problem in
this country of people accessing good
quality rented homes okay one fewer to
rent if they're not replaced but the
tories say that under their plan they
would replace every house that's sold
with another yes but why not just build
the homes if they can find money we've
been through five years of austerity
economics
designed to get the debt under control
there's been no money for housing during
that time we've built fewer than half
the new homes that we need if now we're
able to find money by selling high value
council homes then what we should do is
build new homes we have a housing crisis
in this country not an ownership crisis
the tourists say that this plan allows
individuals to own their own home
something that many people in this
country aspire to do it allows them to
do that plus it provides money that
allows new houses to be built it doesn't
satisfy everybody no the conservatives
say that they reckon this will cost 4.5
billion pounds a year
give that money to housing associations
and we could build a million one million
new homes for shared ownership that
would give a million households a fruit
on the housing ladder this is not a good
use of the money and it's not sensible
for the state to be requiring private
independent social enterprises to
dispose of their assets that's a pretty
stalinist thing for a conservative
government to want to do so you think
that the housing stock would be depleted
under these plans to you and if that's
right by how much so in 35 years of the
right to buy there has never ever been
an occasion where they've managed one
for one replacement three years ago when
the right to buy for council housing was
refreshed
grant chaps who was then the housing
minister guaranteed one for one
replacement the very best they've
managed is just less than half of that
so yes what we need more than anything
else in this country is new homes and
then we need new high quality homes for
people to rent or for shared ownership
giving huge sums of money to individuals
to allow them to buy homes when they are
already among the best and most securely
housed people in the country is not a
good use of that money